knife crime is at a near record high
with more than 40 blade offenses every
day in london
members of this gang in north london
admit they've carried and used knives
since the ages of 10 or 11
and have become embroiled in postcode
rivalries with other gangs
if somebody touches me here dog oh my
whole gang's gonna come to you your
whole family's getting killed
i have a way if you touch me i'm
touching your whole family yeah
if you touch my bridge and if you touch
him him him i'm coming after you
the taller gang member with the redhead
scarf is an elder looked up to by the
others but it seems this group is given
tasks by people
higher up the chain in return for
perceived protection
or acceptance into the game we didn't
choose this life
right i'm not going to speak about what
happened to me but i know that i didn't
want this but i had to do it because if
i didn't do it
i would die in like a couple of days
what do you mean you would have died in
a couple of days
can you just elaborate a little bit
[Music]
the elder shuts him up people are dying
over nothing
like stopping each other for like
nothing just for the money
when you say just for the money i mean
if you're stabbing someone is them
where do you get the money from is it
what do you do what i mean is it is it
you're saying right you're going to take
over their clients
i've got people that will call me and
say they want someone hurt
[Music]
that's the life that i need you know i
mean but you do you just watch somebody
you don't even know yourself but your
mates told you
because they don't know who i am yeah
if i hit them
we're going to be uh doing some
intelligent slow patrols in the borough
of lambeth
this is what the home secretary hopes
his new measures will tackle
sajid javid says he's increasing the
powers of the police
by introducing knife crime prevention
orders which can be imposed on
youngsters over the age of 12.
if they're suspected of carrying knives
police can put them under curfew
restrict their movements and access to
social media
they'll be tougher measures too against
retailers selling knives to children
and a positive prevention campaign in
the spring it might mean restrictions
in terms of curfews even in terms of the
relationships that they can have with
the gang members it can have a sort of
order on
making them maybe join a a group that
can help them exit from gangs
it can be an education program it's all
about preventing
young people from turning onto a life on
crime and actually
understanding the risks of carrying a
knife but the shadow home secretary says
it's not enough this
may well be these knife crime orders
they may well be
too little too late because they're
taking place against the background of
deep cuts in youth service and you know
cuts the number of police officers
i wonder if you were able to kind of
sit down with the prime minister for a
few minutes
and say i want to explain to you why
i am involved in this life what would
you say i told the prime minister i
didn't choose this lab this lab chose me
if they could come with some sort of
opportunity i would push these out there
but they've got nothing to do what are
they going to do sit on the streets
wasting their life
what else can they do i'll tell theresa
may to put some money
into the youth investment in their
communities
and future opportunities is what they
say they need
you wouldn't expect them to welcome
tougher police powers
but they don't think it will reverse the
trend in rising youth
violence jason farrell sky news